joining us now and and pretty easy to
spot on america's newsroom because she
was the only sober person after the
bengals made it to the super bowl dana
parino was here hey dana perino do you
think hammer had a great time or the
greatest time it was like listen the
fact that he showed up here not in a
toga on monday
i think was a win for everybody i
interviewed him yesterday he was riding
still i know just a heck of a high and
it's fascinating that your co-host has
kind of become the football mascot here
at fox like win one for billy yeah we're
all trying to win one for billy right
now he and i were talking today
i think that the nation is rooting for
the bengals they have to be and i asked
him do you know a single rams fan
in the building
in the building and he said no yeah and
i said well you know replicate the
building across i mean there's just to
me it just doesn't feel like there's a
lot of rams fans yet no i don't see them
i mean if they win you know this town
works they'll be you know everybody
who's wearing like a giants hat
yesterday will be wearing you know what
at this point but it is fascinating and
i'm just i'm so happy for him i'm so
happy for cincinnati because those are
our people by the way i love cincinnati
how about joe burrows parents that's
just a wonderful story i asked i love
that he got to go home right the joe
burrows such a talented young guy um got
to go home yeah that's amazing that was
great does that happen uh i i asked
hammer if he's gonna get one of those
joe burl chains because joe burrow walks
around like a mr t starter set he's got
a lot of bling really i didn't yeah so
if you start seeing hammer with his
glasses i didn't realize how tall he is
until he was um being interviewed by one
of the
sports reporters on the sidelines after
the game and she's she must be fairly
as a as a very short person myself i can
say she looks short to me but when they
stood next to each other like wow he's
tall yeah it was like it was a monster
no i i i watched that same image as you
i think everybody's invested in the same
way that cincinnati's just the better
story and yes and also about evan
mcpherson what a delight he comes on
your show i told him he knows where his
bread is buttered yeah my my only
loyalty to the rams is i kind of look
like their coach sean mcvay if he let
him go i can see that i look like
lettuce yeah the behind the music
version is sean mcveigh where he wins
the super bowl but now he takes a wrong
turn and he wants somebody
excuse me home team home team on netflix
it just came out oh then i didn't see it
okay so it's sean payton isn't it right
the coach of the saints is that what i'm
talking about yes but it's it's it's
kevin james sean payton is that the one
who picked it up yes yes i think that
brian killed me interviewed him the
other day i didn't i didn't even
remember that as a story i barely
remember that as a story about all that
scandal yeah yeah yeah but the saints
but i think it's kind of cool yeah i
didn't know that he goes back to his
hometown and coaches the little league
football team yeah it's actually like
kind of a really nice story yeah you
know redempt talk about redemption and
i'm not supposed to talk little league
sports just because of my gambling
problem i've lost a lot of money at
t-ball over the years perino it's not
pretty yeah how is it going with the new
sports betting here are you into it uh
so far i'm actually i'm doing okay if to
answer the question of how it's going uh
i am is it fun
there's a thing about gambling the
action is great
uh the outcome sometimes isn't right but
if you know how to separate the emotion
from the endeavor gambling's phenomenal
you know there's always that fringe
element that isn't and that that goes
with any vice out so i don't do any of
it but um
i'm fascinated by a public from a public
policy standpoint i had a chance to talk
to chris christie once about this and
when he was governor and the legislation
was going through to allow sports
gambling in new jersey
he said that they estimated
uh 200 to 250 billion dollars in tax
revenue the first year okay do you know
what it actually was or was it bigger
750 billion dollars really
that's insane so that's that's why
you're going to see other states are
going to say well why why would we let
that happen in new jersey and not here
as a former cab driver my first reaction
to that 750 billion number is and
they're still charging 23 to cross the
george washington bridge exactly well
and get and get this
here's another thing that he told me
because
with the technology you can see where
the
that's coming from yes where they're
coming from so like a little ping type
thing
so many of them were happening at like 9
20 in the morning right across the
bridges
as you went over the bridge so you could
do all your
and then you would go back home to new
york location location so you're
spending 23 23 so go place your bet
trying to win that tow money that's what
happens i don't even bet football but
these tolls got so pricey dana perino is
in studio we're talking about the great
bill hammer and sports gambling we've
all been pulling for hammer the other
thing we're always pulling for here at
fox is obviously the police um as a
former white house presser terry i
wanted to ask you this uh we were almost
surprised to see jen saki displaying
what i would consider to be it was
almost like an indifference to the spike
in crime when she was talking on the pod
save america podcast and i didn't think
her clarification was much better are we
reading too much into this or did she
seem a little flippant
well
both right a little bit so
i haven't actually had a chance to talk
about this uh and so i'm glad i do
because we have a little bit more time
yeah radio's the best we're here exactly
um
she says she was taken out of context
but if you
read the entire transcript of what she
said i don't think it's all that much
better yeah but here's a problem have
you ever have you ever listened to pod
save america not a ton i mean not not
consensual you would probably want to
yeah several hostage situations began
with yeah
but those are her friends
and do you know the worst interview to
do is the one with your friends it is
true especially if you are the white
house press secretary because you're i
didn't even there wasn't even a podcast
situation when i was press secretary
right but so here she is chatting with
her buddies
right and you think well is this how
they talk about us behind closed doors
probably maybe but but unfortunately
sometimes you let down your guard all of
us could be on camera or on a mic at all
times and that is a
uncomfortable way to live to be on guard
all the time
however the white house press secretary
job is one
that is extremely serious and it did not
reflect well on
her but forget that yeah she can handle
that it's it doesn't look good for the
president and the point they were trying
to make and on substance what they'll
say is the president um offered all this
money an american rescue plan for cops
and the republicans voted against it and
then you dig a little deeper like wow
even the washington post has three
pinocchios because that money was here's
a
crapload of money and cities and states
you can decide and they didn't say you
can't spend it on cops but it didn't say
you must spend this to shore up the
police but that's not even the problem i
think that more money for police uh and
first responders across the country is
always welcome
it's not just the money
it's the policy
it's the progressive prosecutors and
what they don't seem to understand is
that the democrats fully 100 own
the progressive prosecutors and when you
had the young widow
at the funeral last week who
specifically said alvin bragg you are
the problem and i hope that my
just
killed husband is speaking through me to
you the democrats seem to not realize
that this is happening yeah and project
forward to the end of november 2022 and
all these media they're going to go out
and do stories about
wow america was really worried about
crime how did we miss it
it's so funny
that's a great medium impersonation by
the way
i'm really good at those
what do you got come on so when i would
brief president bush and i would go in
and say here's the questions you're
likely to get today and we would go
through them but he said he's a great
compliment to me is he said he was never
surprised by a question when i briefed
him for a press conference great but
what he doesn't say is that i could nail
the tone
almost the exact language
by which the question was going to come
dana perino you can see her at the
mirage hotel and casino this weekend the
woman of a thousand voices uh no it's
that's hilarious to me and i do think to
your point that they are so wildly out
of touch with a lot of basis basic
issues that aren't even partisan issues
crime is not a partisan issue okay they
might have partisan stances but it
affects all americans just the same as
inflation there's almost been like a
defiance like when it comes to areas
where they're failing the country
they've emphasized perception over
reality and i think the average person
doesn't have the luxury of basking in
the perception if the street's not safe
if they can't afford goods and that's
where i think they're setting themselves
up for like a real problem but what i'm
fascinated by is you know they do have
like you know consulting firms they do
have focus groups they do have strategy
firms
are people as strategy firms as derelict
in their duty as these politicians are i
think that as you've seen this political
realignment which is a fascinating thing
to live through right when i was kid the
democrats had the working class
completely
that's flipped gone and so who now are
the consultants yeah they are the
friends of the people that are in power
yeah so and they all
and i remember this in particular in
washington
reporters who were in the briefing room
often were dating the people who had
been in the clinton administration
right and vice versa and then it
happened in the obamas
bill clinton was dating the people in
the clinton administration it was kind
of a thing uh which brings me to jeff
zucker we talk about dating uh he is
apparently resigned after admitting to
an affair with uh or at least a
relationship anyway with a colleague
that he hadn't previously disclosed my
question to you because we don't have a
lot of information at our disposal right
now so we can speculate
let's just speculate right recklessly
that's the whole joy of reading i mean i
just said that jen sackey shouldn't do
that on pod save america so i shall not
do that here but hold on a second i
sometimes think when you look at the
ratings difficulty they've had at cnn
and i do believe their biggest
viewership is from you guys playing cnn
clips on the five and laughing at them
100 it is right it's 100 it is okay
i do think this might have been you know
part of a larger issue you know in that
there was a ground swell to get him out
of there anyway and there might have
even been is someone said to me off the
air maybe some residual effect from the
chris cuomo fire i think that's 100 what
it was you think it was oh yeah
absolutely absolutely because chris
remember where what's the last name
cuomo
you're from new york right yeah you know
the you know the how the politics is
done
with the cuomo family the world of
paybacks and this is all just breaking
news that jeff zucker's made this um
announcement right and um so i haven't
had time to go back but i recall and i
think i said it on the five publicly the
day that chris cuomo was let go he
issued a written statement
in which he alluded to some sort of
thing if you haven't seen the last of me
and if you think you're going to do me
like this just wait and see what happens
to you wow it was something more subtle
than that but that was the sentiment so
as soon as i thought saw that i had
three thoughts number one everyone must
watch the five tonight because i cannot
imagine how bad it's gonna be number two
i was like how much longer till this
show's over because i gotta call greg
gutfeld
and number three
chris cuomo
figured out a way to take down goliath
wow that's heavy stuff but i i kind of
believe it because i totally believe no
of course because they're not the kind
of people that just go away and forget
about it these are not wash your hands
water under the bridge people these are
throw somebody off the bridge
exactly absolutely fascinating stuff
have you ever had a bigger tease for the
five i don't know but can you think of a
segment or another
what's the show that's gonna happen
like a media comeback and it will be
chris cuomo
andrew cuomo and jeff zucker
well i i listen i have a theory i've
discussed this with kennedy i think at
some point you are gonna see networks
start to hire back people who've been
thrown out you know you might see a matt
lauer five years from now as is heinous
as it sounds maybe i could see a world
where they morally justify anything at
the moment it's interesting right so no
he didn't like for example like a matt
lauer he didn't go to jail nope so how
do you how do you pay your debt that's
the thing the society in in in an era
where we don't have a sentencing
guideline that's the biggest challenge
you know we were talking about this with
whoopi goldberg today and i think it
expands on the point you made earlier
about the parties kind of switching
roles the left was the free speech party
for most of my life they were the you
know sex drugs and rock and roll rage
against the machine and people who got
rich singing about raging against the
machine like neil young are now like
screw you i'm with big pharma i'm with
big government it's just mind-blowing
isn't it really strange have we gotten
so here's the question have we gone to a
place where our politics are so hyper
partisan and emotional that they're
denying people their self-awareness
people don't realize how crazy they look
to everybody else i think that's true
especially look at the pandemic yeah and
all the masked craziness and the
nonsense i was i am encouraged that this
latest poll from monmouth says that 70
of the country says
let's move on with the pandemic um we
now have this report from johns hopkins
university that came out today that said
guess what lock downs don't work and
they cause more harm than they benefited
in terms of getting the cases down and
now we're finding out that the school
situation is complete disaster and that
mass don't work so why are children
still having to wear masks at school
that one drives me crazy i think i would
be if i if i had children i think i
would become a militant parent you'd be
bad you'd be the school board mom but
you want to know something there within
their right to be a domestic terrorist
you would be banned by merrick garland i
wouldn't be allowed to have you in my
studio right now you would be going
through metal detectors i would have
moved back to wyoming frankly oh man
wyoming sounds great doesn't it isn't
space i mean it is cold i know i was i
was just in arena i was just in reno
doing my show last week and now just i
love the west i love the place i love
the mining towns i love the relaxed
culture let's let's plan a road gig dana
perrino i'll be there we'll start the
ticket tape parade when hammer's team
wins but we'll just keep on marching
in cheyenne thank you for this